housing is a fundamental human right
yet across the eu it's estimated that
700 000 people are homeless
that figure has risen by about 70 in the
last decade
and the pandemic is making the situation
worse
well it's it's too difficult because i
can find a war
some days in the week but everything is
closed so i've been
without war with the last three weeks
for it it's a problem for take a shower
supplement everything
the european parliament says there are
far too many people in emilio's
situation
homelessness is one of the most severe
forms of poverty
people who sleep rough often face
violence and discrimination
and it affects other basic rights like
access to health care or education
members want the eu to make addressing
homelessness a priority
we are calling to the commission to
propose an european union framework for
national homeless strategies and further
calls on the member states to adopt the
principle of housing first
rising house prices and job losses due
to the pandemic are likely to further
increase homelessness in the eu in the
coming months
the profile of europe's homeless is also
evolving children
the elderly minorities and migrants
women and families are increasingly at
risk
parliament wants the eu and member
states to take steps to end homelessness
in the union by 2030